der zweijährige Matteo hat seit ein paar
Tagen Fieber und Ausschlag diese
Symptome sieht Kinderarzt Ralf Prügel
gerade häufig die
Hand-Fuß-Mund-Krankheit geht um eine
typische Kinderkrankheit ausgelöst durch
Viren
das geht von alleine weg braucht sie
eigentlich nicht groß was machen seit 17
Jahren hat Ralf brügel seine
Kinderarztpraxis in Schorndorf seine und
weitere 19 Praxen bleiben heute
geschlossen denn die Kinderärzte in
Rems-Murr-Kreis streiken weil die
Gesundheitsversorgung unserer Kinder
massiv bedroht sein sagt er
unsere Arbeit hat sie in den letzten
Jahren dermaßen vermehrt wir machen mehr
Impfungen wir machen mehr vorsorgen wir
haben viel mehr Fragen zum Thema Schule
Schwierigkeiten
Verhaltensauffälligkeiten und also der
Umfang unserer Arbeit hat extrem
zugenommen ohne dass wir mehr Personal
sind und wir schaffen es einfach nicht
mehr
Termine im 10 Minuten Tag
immer neue Impfungen sind zum Beispiel
in den vergangenen Jahren der zugekommen
erzählt er fast 50 Prozent mehr als
damals bei seiner Praxis Eröffnung und
das ist halt dann immer pro Kind dass
sie betreuen halt ein zwei drei
Impftermine mehr und das füllt halt
unsere Kalender von halb acht bis 13 Uhr
arbeiten Sie hier ohne Pause denn die
Schlange mit kranken Kindern ist lang
immer häufiger schließen
Kinderarztpraxen in der Region die
Hilflosigkeit von Müttern und Vätern
bekommen vor allem die medizinischen
Fachangestellten täglich zu spüren und
das ist dann halt schon schwierig das
sind dann halt zu vermitteln dass wir
nur schon darauf aufnehmen und so und
dass ich dann schon schwierig und das
sind manche auch wirklich frustriert
also manche Patienten nur anrufen dann
auch neue Mama Caroline walter hat sich
deshalb schon im November nach einem
Kinderarzt umgeschaut heute ist sie nun
zum ersten Mal mit dem vier Wochen alten
Leo bei dr Prügel zu einer
Vorsorgeuntersuchung
hätte es nicht gedacht also von Hebamme
über Kinderarzt alles ist super
schwierig man muss sich sofort wenn er
eigentlich geplant ist schon drum
kümmern gefühlt er leo hat alle Tests
super bestanden auch der
hüft-ultraschall war unauffällig dr
Prügel ist nach wie vor Kinderarzt aus
Leidenschaft es ärgert ihn aber dass die
Politik versäumt hat mit der Zeit
mitzugehen trotz Bedarf keine neuen
Praxen zulässt
kurzfristig sollte sich vor allem ändern
dass eben dieser Verteilungsschlüssel
besser wird das mehr Stellen pro Bezirk
zugelassen werden dann sollte sich ganz
dringend ändern dass wir Personal
einstellen können also ärztliches
Personal ohne dass wir eben gedeckel
oder budgetiert sind dass er im Moment
noch der Fall ist mit dem Streik heute
so sagt er wird nun hoffentlich allen
klar wie ernst die Lage ist
und über den Streik der Kinderärztin und
Kinderärzte und über dessen Ursachen
spreche ich jetzt mit dem
gesundheitspolitischen Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion im Bundestag Andrej
unzureichende Versorgungslage beklagen
die Streikenden Kinderärztinnen und
Kinderärzte im Rems-Murr-Kreis auch sie
sehen die Versorgung von Kindern in
Gefahr wir sind in Deutschland wie kann
das sein
ich denke da die Faktoren sind
multifaktoriell wir haben doch erkennen
müssen dass die Gesundheitspolitik
zurückgefallen ist in den letzten
Jahrzehnte letzten 16 Jahren ist
eigentlich im System nichts geändert
worden hier müssen wir natürlich Abhilfe
schaffen ist ja übrigens nicht nur in
der Pädiatrie so sondern sehr viel
fachärztlichen Bereichen der Fall und da
müssen wir auch von seiner Politik
agieren und das haben wir auch bereits
gemacht wie zum Beispiel die nbditierung
der Kinderheilkunde in den
Krankenhäusern damit dieser Hamsterrad
in den stationären Versorgung der
Kinderärztinnen und Ärzte weniger wird
und auch gleichzeitig auch eine
sogenannte endgültigen das heißt eine
Entwicklung des Einkommens eines
Kinderarztes oder Kinderärztin fehlt ist
ebenfalls welche gefallen so dass hier
die Versorgung in dem Bereich
kurzfristig verbessert werden kann aber
mittelfristig müssen hier natürlich
Maßnahmen ergriffen werden wie es auch
im Beitrag zu hören war die
Bedarfsplanung zu ändern und auch eine
Kooperation zwischen den niedergelassen
vertragsärztinnen
ten und den Klinikärzten und Ärzte
sprechen wir über die Bedarfsplanung die
Sie angesprochen haben wenn man sich
dieses System mal näher anschaut kann
man sich eigentlich nur wundern ein
Kinderarzt kann nicht so einfach eine
Praxis eröffnen die Kassenärztliche
Vereinigung muss das genehmigen auf dem
Papier gelten manche Gegenden als
überversorgt obwohl im Alltag wiederum
Ärzte fehlen müsste nicht das ganze
Zulassungssystem geändert werden
von Seiten der FDP haben uns ja schon
unlängst positioniert wir würden eine
allgemeine Niederlassungsfreiheit
ausrufen aber die Gefahr ist ja auch
durchaus gegeben da muss man natürlich
ein wenig abwiegen aber hier muss
natürlich die bedarfsverfahren insgesamt
noch neue Füße gestellt werden dass die
Bedarfe auch befriedet werden die wir in
Deutschland auch haben es gibt ja
offenbar einen generellen Mangel an
Kinderärzten der sich ja wohl noch
verschärfen wird denn das
Durchschnittsalter liegt bei der Zeit 57
Jahren ein Viertel der Kinderärzte geht
in den nächsten Jahren in Rente und es
kommen viel zu wenigen nach warum ist
denn der Job so unattraktiv für viele
angehende Mediziner und Medizinerin
diese Änderung des Alters erkennen wir
auch hier nicht nur in der
Kinderheilkunde sondern auch in der
Allgemeinmediziner Inneren Medizin auch
andere facharztbereiche ist das zu
erkennen es ist der demografische
Entwicklung die wir auch in der
Ärzteschaft als solches anerkennen
müssen zwangsläufig nicht desto trotz
muss die Attraktivität aller
facharztbereiche nicht nur der Pädiatrie
besser werden und ein Punkt ist was ja
sie immer wieder hören ist überbauende
Bürokratie da müssen wir jetzt Abhilfe
schaffen das ist glaube ich unsere
Verpflichtungen in der Politik hier da
weniger Bürokratie laufen zu lassen
Digitalisierung könnte hier eine
Arbeitserleichterung bedeuten Punkte die
jetzt auch in der Ampel angegangen
werden
sie haben jetzt ein paar Punkte genannt
trotzdem möchte ich noch mal fragen was
sie denn tun wollen um das Problem zu
lösen dass es zu wenig Kinderärzte gibt
und das immer weniger Medizinstudenten
und Studenten sich dafür entscheiden in
Rheinland-Pfalz wo auch eine Ampel
regiert da wird jetzt über eine Vergabe
von medizinstudienplätzen eine
kinderarztquote von drei Prozent
nachgedacht das soll eingeführt werden
ist das zum Beispiel der richtige Weg
ich glaube wenn wir zu viele planen
wirtschaftlich oder planerische Elemente
einbauen bitte dieses System eher
komplizierter und nicht einfacher hier
wäre vielleicht insgesamt eine Reform
der Studienplatzvergabe zu überlegen ob
jetzt Numerus clauses ein so wichtiger
Punkt ist sein Frage gestellt worden und
hier wäre eine Ausweitung von
Studienplätzen sicherlich viel
sinnvoller und dann bin ich auch
überzeugt dass wir genug Fachärztin
Fachärzte bekommen nicht nur in der
Pädiatrie sondern Problem dass die
Ampelkoalition angehen will aber auch
angehen muss zu wenig Kinderärzte und
Ärztin in Deutschland darüber haben wir
gesprochen mit dem
gesundheitspolitischen Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion im Bundestag mit Andrew
Ulmann vielen Dank
danke Ihnen